nationalistic and echoing a nazi
rallying cry that's how russia's foreign
ministry sees ukraine's new football kit
for the euro 2020 championships
that start later this week the front of
the kit features a map of ukraine it
includes crimea even though the
peninsula rejoined russia in 2014
and below the cholera it displays the
slogans glory to ukraine and glory to
heroes associated
those slogans with the country's
pro-nazi paramilitary groups during the
second world war there frequently as
well
slogans heard it far right
demonstrations and it made a spike in
nationalistic sentiment in the country
russia's foreign ministry spokesperson
maria zakharova says that such gestures
have no place in sport
this is another attempt by k of state
propaganda to consolidate in the public
consciousness a slogan
that many ukrainian abroad associate
with the ukrainian insurgent army
led by stephan bandera and their crimes
during the second world war
crimea continues to be a thorny issue
between moscow and kiev historically
it's russian
residents voted overwhelmingly for
reunification with russia in a
referendum
though ukraine still considers crimea to
be part of its territory
the european football's governing body
uefa insists ukraine's euro 2020 kit
does meet with the organization's rules
that despite though saying in their
charter quote
provocative messages of a political
ideological
religious or offensive nature are banned
we spoke to sports columnist alan moore
who says
ukraine's created an unwelcome
distraction for his place
there's no point other than just trying
to kind of um get attention or to
deflect and
probably to deflect from a pretty bad
performance because uh they're not going
to be
set in the world of light that's for
sure these euros every every country
every country uh with the kind of who
who wanted to try and
show themselves who feel kind of lacking
in self-confidence will always push
themselves forward like that
to like big up their past so you've got
this
you know i i guess you could say like
this predilection
for showing off when a lot of nations
are not so sure of their actual
nationwide so that might be the case
in the case with uh ukraine right now i
think this is a really bad move from the
ukrainian fa they could have done this
an awful lot better
and i don't think the most
right-thinking and intelligent fans will
be back in ukrainians on this one